in südhessen riss ein wolf drei schafe
er konnte sich durch einen extra
errichteten sicherheitszaun hindurch
winden kam dann an die tiere heran der
betroffene bauer tobias pooth hat nun
nicht nur angst um seine tiere genau
darüber möchte ich jetzt sprechen mit
ihm selber ist mir nun live zugeschaltet
airport was genau ist wird ihre herde
passiert ja sagen ich ganz einfach der
vulva da hat drei schafe chris das waren
eigentlich die einzigen drei die wir
hatten wir haben ja dann wie gesagt die
drei schafe zwei hatten davon gelangt
weil immer noch dazu dass eine scharf
war trächtig gewesen und in der nacht
auf der 18
5 wasserdampf so weit dass der wolf bei
und zwar als das war natürlich ein
schönes erlebnis
wie geht es denn den lämmern wurden auch
diese von dem wolf gerissen
komischerweise wurden die bomben
verschont
das sind jetzt natürlich dilemma die
zwei einzigen die wir jetzt noch haben
und die bedeuten natürlich eine erhöhte
fürsorge weil er die mutter die mir da
ist die waren relativ jung die bahn
personals gewesen als der wolf da sie
konnten dadurch nicht alleine ernähren
und das war schon erhöhter aufwand damit
wovor haben sie jetzt am meisten angst
die angst ist natürlich bei
hauptsächlich haben wir eigentlich mit
akkubetrieb der wolf ist ja nicht nur
rehe und schafe der macht auch
jagdhelfer obwohl zwei polen aktuell
auch noch und da ist einmal da die angst
und als nächster ist jetzt auch noch
weiterhin so dass natürlich dass man
seine kinder auch irgendwo angst hat ja
weil die kinder sind ja wenn sie alleine
spielen dürfen auch und gefunden das
wissen irgendwo auch wenn es heißt dass
die dass die wölfe sparwasser die
erfahrung habe ich jetzt gemacht das
nicht unbedingt so sein muss aus dem
einfachen
und walter wolf direkt hinter der
wohnbebauung stattgefunden hat vielen
dank herr fotos sie uns das geschildert
haben wir wollen jetzt noch etwas weiter
sprechen über die gefahr solcher
wolfsangriffe mit markus stifter ist mir
nun live zugeschaltet stifter die erste
frage erst war wie weit verbreitet sind
wolf überhaupt in deutschland und vor
allem wie oft kommt es zu solchen
angriffen hier bei uns einen schönen
guten abend angriffe auf schafe sind der
vergangenheit ingesamt hessen häufiger
gegeben
wir haben uns in hessen hier zwei
sesshafte öl finden und zwar einmal im
vogelsberg und einmal im sogenannten
stoßsicher gebirge in nordhessen
da ist es bereits mehrfach zu
übergriffen auf weite tiere bekommen
wie gefährlich ist diese situation für
menschen bisher gab es auf menschen noch
keinen angriff man weiß allerdings aus
bestimmten bereichen auch gerade aus dem
vogelsberg dass der wolf sich dort auch
in der nähe der menschen aufgehalten hat
und das gilt es jetzt weiterhin zu
beobachten um zu schauen ob der wolf
weitere verhaltensauffälligkeiten zeigt
der mensch kann dieses verhalten aber
auch mit steuern das heißt wir sollten
auf keinen fall wenn man eine begegnung
mit dem wolf hat versuchen ihn
anzulocken im futter zu erreichen oder
irgendwie vertraut zu machen mit den
menschen wird dann können es natürlich
dazu kommen dass der wolf ein vertrautes
verhältnis aufbau zu den menschen und
sich dann auch bewusste menschen nähert
weil er gelernt hat von dem futter zu
bekommen zum beispiel